welcome to this video playing ml raka I
think this is a growing MRSA or at least
it strong title player from other by
John but I think they need to have
played one move to know and to get the
title and am I wrong here it's no name
in there let's rating to 3690 are you
kidding me are you totally kidding me
okay so this guy is blitz rating or had
a blitz rating when he was playing
couple of years ago that is unknown
Nakamura level this is somewhat high
okay and I have played for for some
reason that opens the Syrian okay so he
went for the dragon gym I played an
classical somewhat somewhat lame
variation against this but I cannot
don't know anything about the about them
and the these long castling lines 95 we
might take night c5 and I've should see
form and be to Hanks okay so maybe just
go back here I am this Bishop only six
is not so ideally placed
so yeah I can take on c3 actually no
it's not doing that so he's trying to
win easy for porn or what exactly and I
don't know he's playing quickly that
much is clear yeah this must be a very
strong player here from other by Johnny
his five minute rating is is distorted
it's just you just had ten games or
something and five minutes so he's
actually am stronger I mean 3700 and
blitz this is this is the kind of rating
that only in the camera agree shook
Milosevic those those super guys were
able to to get but still I have a good
position here I am I not just fine Queen
III I was also thinking this is a kind
of ugly pin and if i move the bishop he
will take be too probably i can just
take it seven as well
Queen III 25 it's not leading to too
much I think a camera to take him not so
not not an easy decision for me and be
to hang so play play b3 hmmm I need some
some am I could have taken the paw but
the sword is too late ready
yeah we both have weaknesses in the pawn
Sampat this is really something that
that I should shouldn't have any big
problems with this position but you
never know what kind of trouble you can
get yourself in
I hope I'm not blundering this to a
silly tactic can easily happen I know
I'm vulnerable to to those now you look
at the right knee looks like and the
favorite here but that's not the case
he's really am very much under rated him
i have f 3 f as a safe spot
yeah that's not that much going on but
he's got more time on the clock
and not sure what okay wants to do this
on what I mean any well it's it's it's
totally dead anyway but you will play on
time I'm pretty sure about that bra
Arvind I can offer this draw that no of
course not ha ha ok game hello sir this
makes I mean this is really totally
boring to to shuffle all the time so I
am managed to hold this I don't know I
would like to know who this is probably
very strong player it can look at this
year he's got 3,600 in blitz which is
yeah I think Nakamura is best rating
were 3,800 or something so yeah somehow
here I think I should be in a pretty
good situation but it's nothing too
serious probably Queen III a thought but
they escaped please got this one you
know c3 was a threat but she can protect
the Queen yeah in around here I don't
know it is equal ish but I should take
cb7 I I really didn't see that i was
playing this too quickly and here i
think we're just talking about an equal
position with everything getting getting
traded down check here you can as long
as you don't blunder some some silly
stuff it's really a wrong yeah there
wasn't much happening in this game still
it would be curious I'm curious to know
what this is okay well thanks for
watching